so the smartphone revolution the
revolution in connectivity has created
an on-demand economy as Kevin Kelley
says access is now more important than
ownership the idea that goods and
services are just a rub on a magic
mirror away from being fulfilled this
notion of extending our will magic as
Aleister Crowley described it as willed
intent
I summon and it appears as I imagine so
it becomes and this is the very essence
of Magic's great line and this is the
world that we're living in now services
like uber services like Airbnb that will
literally summon the ability to go stay
somewhere and the means to get there at
the speed of thought almost are scaling
to the point that we are seeing a
transformation in our phenomenological
experience we are creating a
technologically mediated flow where most
of the world becomes an extension of our
agency I mean even the fact that uber
can sync with your Spotify playlist so
that when you summon the car to take you
to the place that you want to go the car
arrives and the music that you've
previously soundscape is already playing
in the car giving you the serendipitous
experience of moving into spaces where
all of a sudden everything's amazing
this is the Sun I like this is a place I
want to go oh let's go somewhere oh
here's the car picking me up oh my god I
want to go stay at this beautiful
mountain town oh my god here's the
apartment waiting for me just an Airbnb
again I mean this on-demand economy is
transforming subjectivity when we
Surinder into it when we surrender into
the space and the speed
of the feedback loops between our
creative choices and what is able to be
summoned for technological extensions
our technological scaffoldings we
actually step into a new space of
consciousness we step into a new way of
perceiving reality the whole thing
becomes mental architecture but we
cognate eyes the world
that's the AI revolution that is the
on-demand economy we extend our
cognition our mental neuro architecture
out into the world it all becomes green
space it all becomes a little city dream
it all becomes an inception that we can
control that's the flow that is promised
by the on-demand economy I find it very
exciting very exciting
you